Square,
say something about your relationship
with your father when there was not much
of a relationship because he was always
absent.
My parents divorced very early on and he
was,
he lived in a,
in a world of after the collapse of,
of Germany and the destruction of
Germany.
He fled into,
into,
uh,
his kingdom of fantasies and he
fantasized about writing a universal
study and he had to study a.
He actually studied biology and history
and psychology and he spoke eight or
nine languages including Japanese and he
refused to work and he refused to earn
money because he was working on the
study in his wife's,
always had his women always had to earn
money and race of children and cook the
food and he was resting and taking
notes.
He never wrote one page.
What influence did it never wrote?
One page.
I also know that the Dalai Lama told you
that every person is at the center of
their own universe and you replied
that you have to add.
He said,
well,
in that definition I would be the center
of the university laughs.
And he says,
and you would be the center of the
universe,
and youth said,
well,
without missing a beat,
I said,
your holiness,
please don't tell that to my wife.
So by the way,
yes,
people always a,
it starts out that,
uh,
we are talking about some obsessions now
more than any obsessions or anything.
There's humane may films including even
to our,
started small,
but it's a very dark sort of humane in
the bad lieutenant.
Audiences laugh more than in a,
in a fred,
Eddie Murphy comedy.
They laugh from the first til the last
minute.
And this is wonderful to see that people
finally accept my kind of humor.
And I really liked it.
I think you're pretty funny.
No,
no,
I'm not a.
How should I say?
I have,
I certainly have humane and it should
not be overlooked.